hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today were going to
be going over a game from the 1959 u.s.
championships between Bobby Fischer and
Robin old US Junior Championship at this
time before I get into that again this
is another video in the series for the
upcoming graphic novel Bobby Fischer the
knight who killed the Kings so I thought
to be cool to actually show you guys the
book the first chapter is out for you
guys to preview so definitely would like
some feedback on that you can just head
over together feel calm we're also going
to have a link in the video description
below so definitely want to check that
out but the graphic novel is coming
along very very nicely so I think you
guys are definitely going to be pleased
so again chapter 1 is ready for preview
so I'll kind of go and open it up and
show you guys what it looks like there's
two different ways that you can actually
view it you can kind of scroll through
it with with the scroll bar or you do
have the option if you want to do kind
of a book style the kind of two pane
right here so you can kind of flip the
pages like this as you can see that the
artist Street is just amazing it kind of
obviously goes through you know the the
childhood of Bobby Fischer we also see
you know Spassky in here kind of shows
that they're different lifes one from
the 1950s in America one from the Soviet
Union but but obviously you're going to
be seeing a lot of chess in here so
definitely really cool you're going to
see a lot of character development
you're going to get a lot of insight
into Bobby Fischer's life and you're
going to be seeing you know some great
chess and some great illustrations
definitely definitely one of the coolest
graphic novels that you're ever going to
see so these tie-in again with these
videos that kind of were going over kind
of going over Bobby Fischer's life some
of his games that he's played in the
past so this is just going to give you
more insight into Bobby Fischer if
you're a fan so definitely check it out
this is freaking awesome stuff let me
know what you guys think
so we will go ahead and get into the
game again this is 1959 this is the US
Championship between Bobby Fischer at
this point he's 16 years old he's just
won the past two championships this is
his third in the row that he'll be
playing in and he's playing Robin old so
if you're not too familiar with Robin
old he is a three-time champion for the
US Junior Championship so he's 17 years
of age at this point he won the US
Junior Championship in 1959 60 and 61
1959 was the first time that they
decided that the winner of the US Junior
Championship would go and actually play
in the US Championship so he is there
he's actually a year older than Bobby
Fischer Bobby Fischer the two-time
champion of the US Championship Rob Noll
being the champion of the US Junior
Championship so unfortunately for Robin
olt he actually had a terrible showing
he ended up losing all of his games and
so they decided after this year that
they would no longer invite the the
junior champion to play with the big
boys
this was actually supposed to be dubbed
it is one of the the best matches of two
of the up-and-coming stars on the US
chess scene obviously we have Bobby
Fischer a young 16 year old kid two-time
champion and then Robin dealt the u.s.
junior champion which a lot of people
were saying was going to be the next
Bobby Fischer and kind of compete with
him over a long period of time as being
the top US player so definitely
definitely interesting game to kind of
see the dynamics of how it goes back and
forth this is game number four in the
tournament so at this point Bobby
Fischer definitely has the lead but what
I like about this game is Robin oh
definitely plays for the win he doesn't
play passive he kind of goes at Bobby
Fischer later into the game so
definitely definitely entertaining game
to watch so Bobby Fischer is going to be
playing the white pieces and Robin olds
going to be playing the black pieces and
Bobby Fischer starts out with pawn to e4
again very aggressive opening for Bobby
Fischer he's definitely a very
aggressive player and Robin old decides
to play pawn to d6 Bobby Fischer now
immediately seizes control of the center
of the board and Robin alt plays Knight
to f6
followed by Knight c3 and pawn to g6 now
if you're not too familiar with this
this is the perk defense from black you
don't see it too much in high levels of
play but definitely still playable it's
a great hyper modern defense from black
meaning that black does give up Center
control of the board early on but later
on definitely wants to counter-attack
and soon the board definitely wants to
control the center with his minor pieces
specifically with his night here on f6
and then later on and wants to get his
Bishop over here to g6 and kind of
beared down on the seer and the board
now black does have two options he can
always bring his Knight to d7 and he can
always activate this to b6 or once he
brings it to d7 he can always push
forward with E 5 once he gets his knife
out of the way he can develop his light
square Bishop castle on the Queen side
or again he can always think it was
Bishop here to g7 castle on the Kings
side either way he needs to make sure
that he is staying somewhat aggressive
as White is going to control the center
of the board early on into the game now
what's interesting in this game is one
of Bobby Fischer's famous moves
something that he plays very often is
pawn to f4 now again this is something
he's played in the past even at high
levels championship level play and from
here play would just resume with Bishop
to d7 and then Knight to f3 and then
castle on the kingside from black but
what's interesting is Bobby Fischer
decided to change it up a little bit
obviously he studied this line he knows
a lot of different variations instead of
bringing pawn to f4 which is probably
more of the aggressive move which is why
you see him played a lot
instead Bobby Fischer decides to play
Bishop to g5 again getting this dark
square Bishop involved into the game
early on
typically meaning that this player is
going to castle on the Queen side
anytime you have your knight and your
bishop from one side of the board
typically means you're going to castle
on the Queen side now we can see already
we can probably see a lot of fireworks
typically in the perk defense Black's
going to castle on the King side
although again as we talked about he
does have the option to castle on the
Queen side if he does castle on the King
side and Bobby pits your castles on the
Queen side
sighs you're just going to be throwing
fireworks at each other it's going to be
all about who can attack the opponent
the fastest so from here black plays
Bishop to g7 Khan as we talked about
that hyper-modern defense again fee and
cutting this Bishop to g7 and Bobby
Fischer now plays Queen to d2 again
developing is Queen to d2 getting ready
to castle on the Queen side also wants
to make sure that he's supporting his
bishop here on g5 a lot of times you'll
see this Queen to d2 and then bringing
the bishop over to h6 if there is an
exchange off it's going to be very very
difficult for black to either castle on
the Kings side if he hasn't already or
to do any sort of movement as that King
is kind of pinned down kind of just
sitting there while the queen is on h6
so Kim definitely calls a lot of
problems from here from here alt plays
Knight to d7 very very common move again
this is getting ready to bring his pawn
down to c5 later on into the game he can
always play pawn to e5 definitely a
great support here trying to control
these dark squares and the stern of the
board again remember trying to control
the center with his minor pieces early
on and then he is going to
counter-attack and the center of the
board now White's going to castle on the
Queen side as we talked about before now
he can continue his development getting
his other Knight involved into the game
getting his lights for Bishop involved
to the game gonna be very very easy for
Bobby Fischer to develop now from here
black plays pawn to e5 and this is
actually a mistake simply because it's
much much stronger just to play pawn to
c5 yes you definitely later on want to
be pushing forward pawn to e5 but first
you actually want to play pawn to c5
assuming that you are going to castle on
the King side which in this case the
Perk defense you really need to looking
at is setup right now so you definitely
want to be counter attacking with your
queen side in this case if we kind of
follow the line right here obviously
that the pawns not going to come and
take right there because just going to
be losing a lot and black would still
have his pawn here on these
and his pawn on the e-file but if we
continue the line with Knights f3 simple
development from white trying to control
the center of the board and then after
pawn takes and the knight retakes and
the king castles as you can see here
that although White has his Queen and
his rook here on the D file black still
has both of his pawns on the DME file
he's Castle down the King side has King
side safety also you know putting a lot
of pressure on the center of the board
I can still push forward with pawn to e5
still controlling a lot with his night
here on f6 and also as Bishop here on g7
but instead we can see the problems that
arise with pawn to e5 because now after
the exchange on e5 and the exchange back
when the knight here comes to f3 as you
can see White has much better
development and also this D file is
completely controlled by white so a few
little moves difference and as you can
see white has a slight advantage
although it's not a huge advantage he
does have a slight advantage and his
King is not quite as safe as it was
before
now from here black plays pawn to h6
again trying to alleviate some of this
pressure obviously this Bishop here on
d5 is pinning down this Knight to f6 but
as you can see anytime you think a no
your Bishop to g7 if you want to move
any of your pawns it's really really
going to weaken up your King side so in
this case we may try to see black castle
on the Queen side obviously he's really
really weakening his King side so he
definitely may try something along those
lines
now Bobby Fischer does have the option
he can always trade Bishop with his
night right here on f6 but again top
level play you tip look you're not early
on to the game gonna be seeing bishops
coming off the board just because the
bishop pair is so strong you know until
there's really a fixation of pawns and
you know it's either going to be a
specifically closed game it's very easy
to open up the game which Bishop pairs
do really really well and so Bobby
Fischer decides to bring his bishop back
to h4 and then blacks going to continue
to push forward again weakening his
Kings side a little bit more but
also starting to put a little pressure
on Bobby Fischer kicking that Bishop out
even more the bishop is obviously now
going to come back to g3 and now blacks
going to play Queen to e7 obviously he
wants to continue developing is his
pieces last piece he has to develop his
his Bishop here on c8 but then he can go
in castle on the Queen side he's going
to have a lot of different options
obviously you'll kind of have some
counter play on this D file so things
are definitely looking good for black in
this situation now in this position
White has one thing on his mind he's
already castled on the Queen side he
really wants to focus on attacking on
the King side so that's exactly what he
does white plays pawn to h4 black's
going to kind of counter-attack and play
pawn to g4 kicking this night away now
the knight has two different options it
has one kind of is a passive move one's
more aggressive the passive move is
actually what Bobby Fischer chose to do
not necessarily that's a terrible move
he did play Knight to h2 um he did
actually have the option to playing a
very aggressive move and that is Knight
takes on e5 and then with the exchange
the knight takes and Bishop takes and
then the knight could come down to e4
few ones who attacking this Queen here
and then after the bishop takes the
Queen goes down and then centralizing
this night right here attacking the
Queen and after the Queen comes to c5
then taking the night here on d2 again a
lot of complications for black in this
scenario again this is just going to be
really really entertaining to me and I
thought this would be super super
aggressive but Bobby Fischer probably
played the the safer the easier route
McKinney is playing just the u.s. junior
champion so doesn't want to take too
many risks knows that if he can just
play a solid game he can definitely
probably play outplay him towards the
end of the game so that's exactly we did
he just played Knight to h2 again
passive move but also kind of attacking
this pawn here on g4 as well black is
going to play pawn to c6 really
defending the square here on b5 very
powerful obviously white wants to get
his bishop involved into the game
anytime if you want
to bring his vision to b5 pinning down
this night here to the king always going
to be a good thing so goes ahead and
brings his pawn to c6 to negate that now
again as we talked about before white in
this position still wants to be focusing
on attacking on the King side so he
continues he plays pawn to f3 I get he
wants to make sure that he's attacking
the pawns but also strengthening his
pawn chain so great little move from
here gives him a lot of options if he
ever wants to take back or if he wants
to take with his night here on f3
definitely has a lot of options from
here black's going to solidify as well
going to play pawn to h5 and then why
it's going to bring his king over to be
1 when we see from this move from upon
to h5 is this also opens the door for
Bishop to h6 and this is going to be
pinning down this Queen to the king here
on c1 so definitely ever want to have
your queen your queen pinned down to
your king so definitely wants to make
sure you get the king out of the way
Bishop is going to come to h6 anyway
doesn't really matter but now the Queen
can get out of the way safely without
losing the game obviously he can't move
his queen if his King is on c1 so he
brings his Queen over to f2 still
somewhat active Square does have all
this dark long diagonal to move around
in obviously not quite as active if it
was on d2 so definitely good for for
black to be bringing his Bishop over
tier to h6 anytime you can have your
opponent's Queen less active definitely
going to be a good thing so from here
black plays Knight to c5 and you can see
that black is starting to have a much
better position in the game if you
actually run this through different
engines kind of looking at the position
trying to think about what size what
both sides should do and kind of see
who's better
this is about equal so Black has
definitely managed even though he does
have a weak King side he's either going
to have two casts on the King side and
go completely kamikaze or he's going to
castle on the Queen side and just really
really try to win the king side battle
over here but as you can see he's
definitely done a much better job of
counter attack
in the center of the board he does have
much more active nights in the center of
the board obviously Bobby Fischer has a
night over here on h2 the night here on
c3 is nicely placed obviously
controlling the center of the board but
as you can tell both sides only have one
of their bishops developed and this
bishop right here on g3 isn't doing a
whole lot just attacking this pawn here
on e5 so black even though he has a lot
of pressure up against him playing the
two-time champion and having lost the
first few games of this tournament
definitely definitely playing pretty
well especially 15 moves into the game
now from here Bobby Fischer plays Bishop
to e2 thinking probably would have been
a little bit better if he just played
Bishop to a d3 white away but instead he
plays Bishop to e2 and now blacks going
to play pawn to b5 now this even though
it's kind of a subtle move obviously
he's trying to attack on the Queen side
for white this is a very very important
move because this signifies that it is
all-out war on the chess board because
black can no longer safely castle on the
Queen side so black is either going to
castle on the King side and gonna go
kamikaze or he's just not going to
castle at all and just hope and pray
that Bobby Fischer does not crush his
King in the center of the board so when
I was kind of analyzing this game and
kind of looking at stuff definitely
exciting to see a move like pawn to b5
because this pretty much says black is
not playing for a draw
definitely playing aggressive because
the Queen side is no longer safe for
King to castle on so definitely
interesting from here why it's going to
play a Bishop to d3 good thing about
this he does now have a little bit more
support with his pawn here on e4
definitely controls this long white
diagonal right here it also now has all
of his pieces developed so you always
want to be developing your pieces
towards the center of the board you
always want to have your rooks connected
on the back rank and you want to have
your King Castle on one side of the
other so Bobby Fischer has done that
black on the other hand definitely needs
to develop his LightSquared Bishop and
definitely needs to castle in this
particular case on the king set so
blacks going to play rook to b8 again he
is as we talked about trying to
counter-attack on the Queen side of the
board obviously sees that Bobby Fischer
is attacking on the King side so he's
going to go and attack on the Queen side
Bobby Fischer now plays Knight to e2 and
blacks going to play Knight to a4 again
really starting to put a lot of pressure
in this case putting a lot of pressure
on the b2 pawn and now Bobby Fischer
plays Knight to c1 now this is one of
the more questioning moves that I have
from Bobby Fischer in the game
definitely one of the most passive
squares that this Knight can come to
here on c1 doesn't have a whole lot of
threats that he's protecting with his
night here on c1 and as you'll see this
night really doesn't move for the rest
of the game so not necessarily the best
place for it
but Bobby Fischer plays Knight to C one
and then blacks going to castle on the
kingside which means there's going to be
fireworks for the rest of the game now
white plays pawn takes on g4 so now that
Bobby Fischer knows that black has
casted on the kingside he can now direct
all of his attention to attacking the
king side and trying to checkmate the
black king as fast as possible because
as we can see all of the lines of
defense are going to start trying to get
knocked down by Fischer one after
another after black retakes here on g4
black has a slight advantage in the game
now even though white has a safer King
on the Queen side here black actually
has much more active pieces obviously
this night here on h2 is not very active
the night here on c1 is not very active
although it is slight black hat black
does have the advantage in the game
unfortunately for Robin olt he saw the
light at the end of the tunnel things
were looking so good as soon as he got
his first slight advantage he just
crumbled under the pressure of the rest
of the way it's actually definitely kind
of hard
to watch the collapse there so feel free
to enjoy the rest of it Bobby Fischer
just destroys all the mistakes that
Robin Holt has the rest of the game but
from here Bobby Fischer plays pawn to h5
and then Robin olds going to play Knight
takes on h5 definitely I would have
liked to seen from here you know you
could have always instead of taking with
his knight he could have just brought
his Bishop here to d5 felt like this
would have been a little safer move
because what we'll see after the Knight
takes on h5 then we do have the
discovered attack with the knight coming
here to f1 obviously he's attacking here
definitely wants to bring this knight
involved into the game get it to e3 has
a nice little outpost here on f5 for his
Knight with this pawn here from efore so
nice little move from here black's going
to bring his queen to g5 this is
probably where everything just fell
apart didn't really know exactly what he
was doing was putting a lot of pressure
on Bobby Fischer this move doesn't put
any pressure on Bobby Fischer obviously
he can't really do a whole lot he's
obviously trying to put his queen in
front of the bishop which is good only
to an extent it's not really going to do
a whole lot when the king is pretty much
safe here so he's not really threatening
this night here on c1 so kind of a
wasted move definitely would have been a
lot more not only entertaining but
beneficial if he took on g3 obviously
trading nights for your opponent's
bishops especially if that opponent is
Bobby Fischer since he does so well with
with dual bishops definitely would have
been more creative obviously once the
excuse me the rook takes here on h6 and
now the Queen can come to g5 and then
the Queen can come up here to a7 and
take a lot more dynamic from black here
obviously his king is still in a lot of
trouble but he has a lot of active
pieces he can do a lot where this Bishop
right now is tied up this rook isn't
doing a whole lot and white has both of
his knights on this first rank right
here so definitely thought that would
have been a lot better instead
of attacking and putting the pressure on
Bobby Fischer he decides instead to
bring his queen to g5 which allows Bobby
Fischer to start putting more and more
pressure on Robin olds so he brings his
bishop to h4 again before he wasn't
going to have that bishop now he's that
tacking making Ravenel play the
defensive part as we talked about the
Queen's now going to come back to g6 and
now Bobby Fischer can play Knight to e3
again starting to get his pieces
developed getting more involved into the
game his Knight canal if he wants to
come to f5 much more active pieces from
Bobby Fischer then as we talked about in
our previous example so Robin dole is
now going to play Knight to f4 and Bobby
Fischer is going to play Knight to f5
again this is a fantastic square from
Bobby Fischer obviously you know it
would actually probably be better if
Robin dolt just went ahead and came in
and took this you really never want your
opponent to have an outpost on the side
of the board that you have your King
Castle Don I probably should have just
come in taking that and then after he
takes here then bring the Queen over
here to d6 nice central square for this
Queen right here he does now have both
of his rooks connected nice out posed
for this night here on f4 a nice little
game that black could have had from here
instead of taking right away he brought
his Bishop to g5 not doing a whole lot
of good for Robin old Bobby Fischer is
now going to bring his queen to g3 again
putting even more more pressure on the
board blacks going to play Bishop takes
on f5 now it's a little bit too late
though Bobby Fischer is now just going
to recapture on f5 now the Queen's just
going to be coming back to g7 right here
and then Bobby Fischer is going to play
Bishop takes on g5 now the next move I
kind of feel like is a conceding move I
feel like he could have at least opened
up a trap door for Bobby Fischer even if
he didn't you know fall through it and
lose the game I still feel like he had
another option in this particular place
he plays Queen takes on g5 obviously he
is kind of
position obviously there's just so much
pressure on the Queen's on the Kings
side for black here but to move like
pawn to e4 this is a really tempting
move from Bobby Fischer obviously being
such a strong player he's probably not
going to fall for this but again Bobby
Fischer's human just like everyone else
if he were to make a mistake like Bishop
takes on e4 its gg right there hey
that's that's checkmate that's high
fives to everyone around you just beat
the two-time champion but instead he
doesn't do that again even if he plays
pawn to e4 obviously you know let's say
pawns who see three trying to stop that
checkmate the knight can come over here
to h3 stopping the assault from the rook
right away obviously you can now bring
his knight back to g5 he's still
attacking the bishop there on d3 so a
lot more options that he had instead of
just bringing his Queen to g5 which
still leaves a whole lot of pain coming
his way so from here the rooks just
going to come to h4 getting ready to
swing over and take here on g4
not a whole lot black and dude right now
he's just going to bring his queen back
to g7 obviously the rooks going to come
over so we talked about attacking both
the Knights now going to come to g6
trying to be the saving grace right here
Bobby Fischer says I don't even care
that your Knights there I'm not going to
take it I'm going to push forward just
because I'm better than you does have
the discovered attack obviously with
this Bishop protecting both of the major
pieces the rook and the Queen both lined
up there on the g6 square and now the
Queen is going to come back to H a from
here Bobby Fischer just plays rook takes
on g6 and gg right here this is when
Robin old said you're just too good for
me and I'm gonna go in and lose the rest
of my game so fantastic game from Bobby
Fischer pretty much the entire game he
was just waiting for Robin Hill to make
a mistake it kind of seemed like there
was a few times where he could have gone
for the jugular played a little bit more
aggressive move and instead they kind of
played the more passive moves I'm again
just waiting for his a
want it to crack under pressure that's
exactly what it was and as soon as Robin
ole
made any mistake Bobby Fischer just
pounced on him and it's just much much
stronger in the endgame so one thing
just to keep in mind from this game is
anytime you have a slight advantage as
Robin old kind of did take advantage
never play passive always be moving to
force your opponents play defensive or
move any time your move if you look at
me you're like my opponent doesn't have
to respond to this move at all if you
have the advantage that's probably a
waste so definitely make sure that in
your own games you're taking advantage
when you do have the advantage and then
if your opponent has the advantage try
to take that away from them so hopefully
you guys enjoy this video it's always
fun studying Bobby Fischer's games I'll
learn so much myself definitely
improving as a player getting much
stronger so hopefully you guys enjoy
also make sure you check out the link in
the description for again the graphic
novel Bobby Fischer the knight who's
slain the kings going to be a fantastic
graphic novel I'll definitely check that
out also leave comments let me know what
you think of chapter 1 let me know what
you guys how you think it's progressing
and I will see you guys in the next
video thanks for watching